story time back in early 2021 i kept
hearing all this hype about this new
crypto startup called bitcloud it
promised to offer one of the ideas i
talked about in a previous video i made
on nfts being able to invest in creators
that you support that you think will
grow in the future just like you would
invest in companies you believe in in
the stock market except instead of
owning shares in a crater you'd own the
creator's cryptocurrency coin which in
effect is kind of the same thing and as
a bonus holders of the creators coin
could receive exclusive bonuses from the
creator kind of like patreon patrons do
not a bad idea so i made an account just
to reserve my j-train username in case
the platform took off and i just left it
there because i'm terribly lazy at
trying out new platforms and the jake
tran coin was born with zero followers
zero posts and zero promotion i don't
even think i added a profile picture or
bio at the time it just sat there fast
forward a few months later to july 27
2021 and a friend convinced me that i
should at least try using the platform
at this point i had heard about some
criticism about the platform but i
didn't look into it too much and i
thought that if you used it correctly
and provided some sort of value in
return to holders it could still have
some potential so i gave big cloud the
benefit of the doubt to see what would
happen what could go wrong right i added
a profile picture copy and paste in my
instagram bio and i'll be honest i had
no idea what sort of value i would give
back to shareholders of jake trancoin so
i made a promise on myself to not ask
people to invest and just ask them to
follow the account to get the ball
rolling if and when i come up with ideas
to get value back i made an instagram
story saying i'm on big clout now swipe
up to follow never mentioning anything
about investing in jake trancoin and my
instagram is pretty small so nothing
happened a few people followed and a few
people bought jay trancoin even though i
never asked them to and the price went
up no backlash
ps pause the video and follow me on
instagram jaketrain.io and tag me in a
story of you watching this and i'll
repost it
so i thought okay let's also share my
big clout on my youtube community tab to
see what happens since that will get a
lot more views did literally the exact
same post on youtube i'm on big clout
now click here to follow again didn't
ask you to invest didn't claim we were
going to the moon or that we're going
anywhere for that matter just to follow
i scheduled a youtube post woke up the
next day and boom
apparently i'm now either a scam or my
account has been hacked
well that's strange i had no intention
of pumping and dumping on anyone as a
matter of fact i had no idea what i was
going to do with the account at all i
literally just wanted followers in case
i did come up with a fun way to provide
value to holders but no apparently i'm
afraid now by mere association so i
responded in the comments definitely
haven't been hacked just wanted to test
the waters
wipe the sweat off my forehead tell
myself okay now that that's over with
but no these ridiculous comments kept
showing up everywhere on future
community posts on my instagram on new
videos calling me a scam a fraud
claiming that i lost my life savings on
it wanting a refund what
you pulled out your wallet entered your
credit card information or transfer
crypto into your account but when i
never told you to buy and now i'm the
scam what the f
this is a real message i got from
someone it was never ending to this day
as i'm writing this video the perverted
lust to tear me down was insatiable it
was palpable so of course it got me
thinking am i a scam all of a sudden i
didn't think i was a few minutes before
posting that is big cloud really as bad
as these viewers are making it out to be
what am i missing here is this it is
this how i go down not for trash talking
powerful governments organizations or
individuals before giving a shout out to
a profile i made on a crypto startup
social network thing this is how i'm
gonna get canceled that's kinda lame i
thought i would at least get canceled
for something a little bit more juicy
like being called a racist or heartless
greedy monster of a man or maybe getting
assassinated but a scam that's lame so
what's the story behind big cloud what's
with all the controversies surrounding
it is j tran a fraud a scam a fake guru
dare i say it and most importantly is
this new internet trend of calling
people a scammer just another shade of
cancel culture
so sit back relax and enjoy some
pointless youtube drama
[Music]
companies that are similar to big cloud
are hungry for data analysts and data
scientists it's called the information
age for a reason the people who make the
most money are the ones that are best at
manipulating information to make that
information more valuable and in order
to do that they need people who are able
to make sense of all that data in order
for them to be able to manipulate it in
the most profitable way that's why
companies are willing to pay big money
for people who are good at this if you
want in on this profitable in demand
field that's where today's video sponsor
comes in data camp data camp is an
online learning platform that makes it
easy to build data skills especially if
you've never done anything like this
before they've got over 350 courses
designed by top experts currently
working in the industry so you can
develop in-demand skills today from data
fundamentals the data visualization to
data science coding courses in python
are in sql for example a lot of you guys
are into finance and business so there's
an introduction to python for finance
course that teaches you how to use the
coding language python which i know for
financial analysis they also have
password things like machine learning
with python and much more i recommend
you start with a quick little quiz that
gives you personalized learning
recommendations to start with give it a
try and who knows maybe you'll find that
career path that you really love all the
first chapters of data cancer courses
are free so pause the video and invest
in yourself with my link in the
description box below
in march 2021 around 50 influential
investors received an email with a link
and login to a website with the big plot
white paper
and they were asked to share this info
with one to two trusted contacts but
within weeks there were millions of
dollars being spent a day on the
platform pretty much every major vc firm
wanted to get in on the action sequoia
capital the winklevoss twins coinbase
ventures and more apparently the
platform's founders were completely
taken by surprise what they planned as a
soft launch have become a fully
operating platform within a few weeks so
they went with it a month later the ceo
of bitcloud known only as diamond has
announced that the big cloud exchange
listing api was live and that they were
planning on listing the big cloud
cryptocurrency on coinbase within just
one month of its launch the site traded
more than 250 million dollars and was
worth around a billion dollars already
but what exactly made people flock to it
so quickly big clout is what you'd
imagine if twitter only fans and crypto
training had a threesome love child the
platform is a decentralized social media
and cryptocurrency project that allows
people to invest in influencers they
think are going to become more famous
liked or important in the future
essentially this means that you can bet
on the future growth of an influencer's
personal brand making their coins worth
more on big clout if they do something
that gets them booed off stage for
example that would make the value of
their coins go down users can also send
money or diamonds to people who write or
post things they like as creators gain
popularity and more people buy their
coins the price of these coins go up
because of more demand just like stocks
you could even invest in yourself and
buy some of your own coins betting that
you'll have more clout in the future up
in your investment which is actually one
of the reasons big cloud has received so
much controversy but we'll talk about
that in a minute because to understand
why everyone is trying to cancel big
clout and the people who use it you need
to know how it works
basically you buy big cloud coins using
bitcoin or you can buy a smaller amount
with a credit card you then use your
bitcloud coins to buy or invest in
people on the platform by buying their
creator coins just like jake trancoin so
let's say you think elon musk can only
go up from here you buy a coin or two
because you think more people will buy
elon musk coin in the future pushing the
price of elon musk coin up you could
then theoretically sell your elon musk
coin for more money than you bought it
for but that's where the controversy
comes in which we'll cover in a minute
and every time someone buys a creator's
coin the creator gets a transaction fee
or a founder's reward on top of that the
platform is decentralized meaning that
unlike facebook and twitter big clout
and theory can't be regulated or banned
people like twitter did with trump
you're basically participating in a
stock market for influencers which could
be a great new form of investing but big
cloud could be so much more than just a
space to buy and sell creator coins
there are tons of other ways influencers
can give value to the people that hold
their coins creators could choose to
interact with only the top 10 of their
holders they could give holders access
to pre-sale tickets some people are
offering zoom calls with top holders or
you can do giveaways of art books or
anything that can be transferred online
pushing people to buy more and more of
your coin to maintain that top holder
position continually pushing the price
up and up sure to some people it may
seem a little dark to put monetary value
on everything whether it's art jokes or
even just a conversation but people have
been doing this with platforms like
patreon for years now and no one has
complained and i personally don't see a
problem with it if you disagree let me
know why in the comments so if big clout
is such a unique revolutionary platform
and it seemed viable enough that lots of
really big investors poured a ton of
cash into it why is everyone calling it
a scam
first the developers of big cloud are
all anonymous and the ceo is only known
as diamond hands even though most people
think it's actually this guy named nadir
al naji a former google engineer
cryptocurrency platforms having
anonymous founders isn't anything new
i.e bitcoin the only problem is that
although big cloud is open source its
holdings are all kept on a private
server making it almost impossible to
know who controls the money you invested
as of march 2021 big cloud holds around
170 million dollars worth of bitcoin and
a wallet it has total control over and
we don't know for sure who controls that
wallet another major issue is that
almost six months after it launched
there's still no official way to change
your creator points or big cloud coins
back in the fiat currency or other
cryptocurrencies like there's literally
no option to do it on the website even
though big cloud is trying to get its
coin listed on coinbase which would
allow people to cash out i think this is
the real nail in the coffin for them
because when people think of investing
in something like stocks or crypto they
go in with the expectation that they can
cash out for fiat in this case people
feel deceived and trapped within the big
cloud platform an asset whether it's a
house or big cloud currency is
meaningless if you can't liquidate it or
use it to buy something else but we
don't have any money all we have is this
if it was truly like the stock market or
any market for that matter then you
should be able to easily cash out your
investment back into other cryptos or
fiat so why didn't they add such a
simple yet important feature from the
start if they wanted to seem legitimate
because right now it is kind of like
dave and buster's or an arcade where you
trade your dollars for arcade coins that
you can't use anywhere else or exchange
back in the dollars today some methods
have been made for you to cash out
through what's called an
over-the-counter transaction or using a
third-party big cloud exchange like
bitswap i'm not affiliated with them but
they did put out this handy article that
i'll link below explaining both options
the problem is that since you're still
selling on a secondary market instead of
on big cloud itself there's gonna be
less buyers which means you're gonna
have to sell for a lower price than
what's listed on big clouds and then
there's the issue of big cloud reserving
fifteen thousand celebrity accounts
without their consents they made a list
of fifteen thousand notable influencers
made accounts for them with their
usernames and profile pictures without
their consents and allowed people to
still trade their creator coins even
though the influencers never reserved
their accounts and made no money from it
even though a lot of celebrities have
claimed their accounts this made a lot
of people angry including some of the
celebrities themselves which is totally
understandable selling any kind of
investment to the general public i.e
unaccredited unsophisticated investors
is always risky because whenever the
general public loses money on an
investment even when they know making
money isn't guaranteed at their worst
they'll probably band together and file
a class action lawsuit against you at
their best they'll probably hurt your
reputation by calling you a scam a
lesson that i have now personally
learned i can see both sides on one hand
making it seem as if you're investing in
the influencers themselves that you're
investing in something that they
themselves are putting their name behind
when in fact they haven't is very
deceiving on the other hand there are
platforms like ftx where you've been
able to trade crypto derivatives for a
while now which we covered in our crypto
billionaires video on ftx you can trade
crypto representing different stocks
like tesla 24 7 instead of just during
trading hours you can trade crypto
features leverage tokens or you can even
bet on things like if trump will win in
2024 you're not actually trading tesla
but a crypto derivative representing
tesla except in this case at least
people know they're not investing in the
real thing and there's plenty of other
criticism against big cloud that you can
look up yourself on youtube if you want
to but what is the verdict on big cloud
on one hand not having a built-in way to
cash out is a real problem it seems like
such a simple feature why don't they
just do it already why don't they even
mention anything about it or give a
simple explanation in their big cloud
guide and the fact that their team is
anonymous along with their questionable
tactics doesn't make it look any better
so if you put your money into bitcloud
just know that you're betting that
they're either going to change that in
the future the big cloud coin will get
listed on an exchange like coinbase or
the secondary market will grow to where
you can sell it for around the same
price as what's listed on big clouds on
the other hand it is still a new startup
and every new startup has bugs and
unfinished features if they're able to
fix this issue or get big cloud listed
on an exchange i still see so much
potential for the space first off the
platform will probably explode when
people see a clear way to cash out but
more importantly imagine being friends
with an elon musk at the beginning of
his rise seeing his genius first hand
investing a hundred dollars into his
coin when it was only at ten dollars
knowing full well you can lose all that
money and then writing it all the way up
to over twenty thousand dollars where it
is today turning that initial hundred
dollars into two hundred thousand
dollars people have talked about how
they wish there was a way to invest in
youtubers early on before they popped
off this still could be it but at the
end of the day crypto in general is
still the wild west and with it comes
lots of innovation lots of shady stuff
and a lot of scams and even though
people keep hearing over and over and
over again don't invest money you can't
afford to lose some people still can't
resist that gnawing urge of human greed
and when they fly too close to the sun
some people will go to the ends of the
earth blaming everyone else but
themselves
[Music]
everyone hates on cancel culture
everyone says to themselves that i would
never shame someone like that people
deserve a fair shake innocent until
proven guilty what happened to nuance
until it's them that wants to cancel
someone the perfect example of this
andrew cuomo the former governor of new
york that recently resigned after sexual
harassment allegations never liked the
guy i personally definitely wasn't a fan
of how he handled 2020 so when i heard
of the allegations against them did i
question it did i react rationally and
say well these are just allegations
maybe we should wait for the justice
system to prove his guilt before we
ostracize him no i like many other
critics that are all supposedly against
cancer culture thought good hanging from
the gallows figuratively speaking of
course calm down have i looked further
into those claims besides the few
youtube videos and articles since
noticing myself succumbing to this
irrational hypocritical line of thinking
no don't care enough to as my favorite
rapper nf said i never said i was an
angel i just like to call things for
what they are so whether it's trying to
cancel a youtuber for literally saying
follow me on big clout or cancelling
someone for sexual harassment before
they're proven guilty it's cancelled
culture nonetheless
[Music]
calling people scammers is the new
cancelled culture should i have looked
in the big cloud more before giving a
shout out yes should i have put a clear
disclaimer to not buy my coin and just
follow or if you do buy there's no
built-in way to cash out right now
probably does that make me a scam for
making this mistake no just like other
forms of cancer culture what happened to
looking at the intentions behind
someone's actions instead of taking what
they did at face value jumping to
conclusions right away and not thinking
about it if i went into this with the
intention that yeah i'm gonna pump and
dump this coin because i don't care
about my viewers then yeah call me a
scam but i can assure you that if i
wanted to do that i would have at least
told you to buy the coin and i get it
like i said i still catch myself doing
this all the time we're faced with the
world with too much information and too
little time to process all of it so
judging a book by its cover is part of
our nature but does that mean i'm gonna
apologize to people who claimed i
scammed them absolutely not i know what
i am i have a pretty good idea of my
flaws i am well aware of the kind of
monster i am but a scammer is not one of
them if you're one of those people that
reacted like this to my big clout shout
out if this video opened your mind then
i welcome you back with open arms no
hard feelings but if you're one of those
people and somehow you made it to the
end of this video and you're still
triggered please dear god i invite you
to unsubscribe right now seriously if
you resent me that much why are you
still subscribed you want to know how i
know you're still subscribed because
you're literally the first ones to
comment whenever i post something new
please unsubscribe the button is right
down there don't need you don't want you
courage is a muscle and if you can't
exercise it against small tiny
injustices tiny encroachments what makes
you think you can stand up against
bigger ones and that's exactly why i
will not bow down to the mob and if you
find yourself in a situation like this
and you know you've done nothing wrong i
hope you have the courage to stand up to
the mob as well
well a place like this
a lot of these guys they don't show any
income at all
yeah but you didn't bring me here to eat
and gossip about wise guys
will you catch up with the kids i'll
call george to bring the range rover
around
upstairs
this is a stock exchange there's no
money you can steer really
and why are you people here
[Applause]
this is bad
[Music]
[Applause]
so somehow i found myself in kiev
ukraine for the making of this video or
at the city center right now right at
sunset it is super beautiful let me show
you guys this
there's this famous landmark right
behind me right here so the comment
section i already know is going to be
like a war zone so just have fun down
there and like i mentioned i don't
really like making videos like this
where it's drama or i did this i did
that it's a bit too narcissistic for me
although i i will admit i did enjoy
making this video a little bit but
sometimes you just gotta stick it to the
cancel culture mob so here we are so
excuse this video until we get back to
our regular programming if you guys want
more videos that are a little bit more
personal like around me i don't know why
but if you do let me know in the
comments below and maybe we'll make a
second channel no promises check out our
sponsored data camp because like i've
mentioned before in this channel my life
definitely wouldn't be worth out without
self-education so that's why i love
sponsors like datacamp which will be
linked below and data science is a very
in demand field right now as well but
that pretty much sums it up subscribe to
this channel for more video essays on
the most provocative stuff in the world
of business kind of like this video not
really like it you'll like the other
videos too you can follow me on
instagram for more day in the life kind
of stuff kind of like this at
jaketrend.io that's going to wrap it up
for this video thank you so much for
watching you've been awesome i've been
jake stay dangerous out there and i will
see you guys in the next one
[Music]
you